foreign
[Music]
ladders
foreign
okay so people said they felt like a
shaking in the area
thank you
guys
foreign
Foundation
oh okay
and if I do want to step out of the shop
where do I go
just to make a change
what
do you guys want the person live because
we have her here
yeah let's get her live okay
we're exactly thank you so much what's
your name
what's the last name
all right Sophia okay come in the shot
here all right excellent thank you
ask you to tell me what you've heard if
you could just give us a sense of what
it was like no problem we were actually
in the building right next door through
the parking lot which is the William
Street 161 William Street and that's
actually where classes do take exactly
we're not doing it yet but once we do um
the photo the video yes
so guys just let me know when you're
ready
oh this is insane
oh yes
oh there's gonna be a news conference
you thinking about the gym right now
to increase in fact
I used to go to um when I was a kid
[Applause]
to the window
s welcome next door actually to where
the Thorns are the people
thank you very much for sharing that
with us
throughout the area
and who's coming throughout the area
because that was so cute
across
foreign
Broadway again
it's like old times
and then with your sarcasm in excess too
because just use the pot there Jarvis
gotcha gotcha ready to go whenever
thank you
soon
I don't know
thank you
all right my media credentialed members
of the media with a fresh pass you're
gonna show me your press pass you're
gonna come underneath the sign you're
gonna wait for me here I'm going to
bring you into the location where uh at
the department of buildings NYPD I'm
going to give you a quick update in a
little bit of time
thank you everyone
together
foreign
where is it
all right
[Applause]
are you seeing the picture
you got a camera
correct we gotta do this double time
guys
Botox you gotta press pass
the one two one sounds
foreign
true
you guys are good
oh he's good
foreign
I Need You Now
Nick
heads up folks
[Music]
foreign
I just want to really give you an
overview of uh what happened we had a
parking garage here that's collapsed
Chief Esposito is The Incident Commander
here and he's going to give an overview
exactly what happened I'm joined by the
city council member and the ball
president that represent this area as
well as the police commissioner uh
exactly to really respond to this
incident at this time we only have one
DOA
uh but I I do want to point out that
thank God we had a robotic dog that was
able to go in the building this is
ideally what we talk about uh not
sending a human being inside a building
that's unstable
are we also able to use the technology
of a drone to give a real visualization
of what is happening in this building at
this time this building is completely
unstable and the chief we do not want to
send in someone until we can make sure
the building is short up but using the
Necessary Technology we're able to get a
clear view of what's Happening inside
the building for the most part and do
whatever we can to see if there are any
more victims right now as I indicated we
have one confirmed DOA and chief
Esposito will give you an overview of
what else we have on the ground and
what's taking place chief
uh good afternoon
John Esposito the chief of operations
for the fire department
as far as we can tell so far we have six
patients there were six workers in the
building at the time of the collapse
four of them have been transported to
the hospital in stable condition
we have
one patient that is that has died and we
have one patient that refused medical
attention
this was an extremely dangerous
operation for our firefighters we
responded to a call of a collapse in the
building we had firefighters inside the
building conducting searches the
building was continuing to collapse we
made the decision to remove all our
people from the building
our robotics unit happened to be nearby
they were on scene very quickly we
deployed our robot dog into the building
they were able to give us a video inside
and then we were able to fly our drones
inside to conduct an assessment and
conduct searches although we continued
to make sure that we have everybody
accounted for at this time we believe
that we have the workers that were in
danger in the building all accounted for
all out of the building and that
structure is very unstable we've had
it's a parking garage we've had some of
the slabs a couple of floors of this the
concrete slab floors uh collapse Crush
some of the cars that are inside and
this will be a prolonged operation
I'm going to pass it on to uh to the
police commission
hello at this time we have no reason to
believe that this is anything other than
a structural collapse obviously that
investigation will continue our
preliminary Response Center on making
this area safe that includes traffic
control and evacuating the nearby Pace
University building which was deemed
unstable at that time we will continue
to work in collaboration with our
partners in the fire department in this
effort
good afternoon so
as indicated it's a structural collapse
at this moment and what we observed from
a picture drawn deployed and we observe
that there are four story building all
the way up on caked collapse all the way
to the cellar floor
our Engineers deployed and currently
checking adjoining buildings and
absorbing uh footage from drone pictures
to identify possible reasons for
collapse
uh we're gonna you know continuous
review and research property profiles to
understand the history of the building
certificate of four companies in all
other records and I will update this
information up here
any active work permits and any
violations and at this time I should
mention also that right now uh there are
some active violation on the building
updated back to 2003 but in 2010 was
application filed which not indicated
violation was corrected but it was filed
uh as there are some active permits in
the building one of them is related to
the electrical work on the premise
all of that would be part of our review
we didn't have any file uh 311
complaints on the building and as uh the
acting Commission of dob indicated
there's always going to be part of the
reviewer exactly what happened here
there was no open violations on the
structure
before
certificate as for this building was
issued in 1957 and uh to be used at a
parking garage it's a four-story
building with a seller uh all the way
through is a parking
uh there's not much we have some plans
for work filed in 2010 it's the latest
for installation of the lift but uh Auto
Lift but we currently review those plans
and trying to find out what city they
can bring it up
come on oh man man
we've called on you but somebody we
called on already okay we don't want to
be yelling out all over the place square
miles
so uh command tactical units uh our
robotics unit uh when they go where
either the robot dog or or the the
drones they're able to stream stream the
video directly to our phones directly to
our Command Center uh we're able to
share that uh the great part of that is
we're able to put these uh use the
technology uh to get information and and
reconnaissance without putting off
firefighters lives and our First
Responders lives at risk uh great
advances in technology and uh we've used
the dog before uh this is the first time
uh that we've been able to fly inside uh
in a collapse to uh uh to do this and
and try to get us some information again
without risking the lives of our our
firefighters
foreign
continuing to do searches there are some
cars in there that are crushed we're
trying to see if we can get up close to
make sure that there's nobody in those
cars but as I said before we believe
that we have everybody accounted for uh
we we've sent people to the hospitals to
uh to make sure that the people in the
hospitals are the people that were
working here and are accounted for
uh active We Believe active parking lot
I'm not aware that there was any
construction ongoing
uh some of the hospitals I'm not sure
that we can get that for you
uh
I'm not sure yet where all the injured
was there was a a worker that was
trapped on the upper floors he was
conscious and alert and moving around
calling us he just couldn't get down and
we were able to put firefighters up
there in the building and take him out
uh across the roof to another building
and bring him down safely
foreign
all of that I'm not sure of yet I don't
know that there were people that were
trapped I think they were just injured
uh with the exception of the one that we
removed from the upper floors
I'm sorry about
uh we're still evaluating that at this
time
uh that's our thought right now but
we're still looking to confirm that
at this time we that's what we believe
and we're still working to confirm that
go ahead
he's all partly all part of the
investigation that Gob is going to do
uh we're not sure until uh until we
confirm and and dob makes their
assessment that it's all safe
we believe he yes he was a worker in the
building
hello man we have a mechanism to let
everybody when they get back in their
building we'll make sure that you're
able to get that information
thanks for watching
foreign
[Music]